bonsoir à vous messieurs merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france
alors cet impôt minimal mondial qu'en
pensez vous philippe béchade
c'est un vieux serpent de mer mais il
fallait effectivement que le port donc
que le projet soit porté par une voix
forte donc ça sera celle de joe biden
quand les etats-unis parlent on va dire
que le reste du monde écoute voir
obtempère on se rappelle que les
américains avaient réussi à obtenir de
la suisse la divulgation du nom des
contribuables américains qui s'étaient
réfugiées donc dans la confédération
helvétique
et pour ça évidemment il disposer d'un
levier qui était que le si la suisse ne
me tord en paieraient pas ses banques
pourrait très bien se voir privés de
licences bancaires aux états unis
personne ne pouvait évidemment envisager
de se priver du guichet de l'art de la
fed aujourd'hui la question à savoir
qu'est-ce qu'elle de quels moyens de
pression disposerait les états unis pour
l'instant l'extérieur tout démontre que
c'est surtout au travers des échanges en
dollars que les états unis peuvent ou
non me sanctionner des pays qui à leurs
yeux ne joueraient pas le jeu
alors la main les questions de 15%
d'imposition on était parti de 21
donc ça évidemment ça va provoquer des
cris et comme d'habitude dans un
marchandage on annonce on lance les
enchères très haut
et puis passant on redevient un petit
peu plus raisonnables et 15% passé juste
finalement deux et demi pour cent de
mieux que l'irlande est en gros la
suisse que je citais qu a également un
taux d'imposition moyen autour de 2 15%
jean marie harribey alors on sait que la
france l'italie l'espagne l'allemagne
ont l'intention de d'adopter une
position commune portée comme l'a dit
philippe béchade par les états unis
allez nous donner votre avis là-dessus
mais aussi le contexte de crise
sanitaire aussi qui pousse un peu les
pays justement à trouver des solutions
pour renflouer certainement les finances
publiques
tout à fait et vous avez bien fait
d'introduire la discussion par en
rappelant que pendant que le g7 finances
se penche sur la question de l'impôt sur
les bénéfices des multinationales
il ya un autre g7 qui se penche sur la
mise à disposition des vaccins pour tous
les pays dans le monde et notamment pour
les pays les plus pauvres qui pour
l'instant sont pénalisés par l'existence
des accords sur la propriété
intellectuelle mais c'est un autre sujet
mais tout à fait lié à ce que vous
disiez effectivement alors donc le g7
finances se penche sur une question qui
est un qui traînait depuis tellement
longtemps que peut que se réjouir qu
elle soit enfin abordé officiellement
parler les grands chefs d'état de ce
monde mais le problème comme 'le mon
collègue vient de l'indiquer
qu'effectivement après avoir annoncé 21
% quand même ton minimal sur l'impôt des
bénéfices des sociétés et dia le taux
est tombé à 15 % et l'observatoire
européen sur la fiscalité qui a été créé
dans les jours précédant ce séjour s'il
a dans les jours précédents a vient
d'indiquer que 15 % étaient notoirement
insuffisants pour faire face aux
immenses besoins qui se posent à nous
que dans les domaines sociaux
écologiques et sanitaires depuis
maintenant presque deux ans donc là la
discussion va être serré pour avoir un
taux d'imposition qui permettent aux
états de faire face au financement
nécessaire pour couvrir ses besoins et
le la bataille donc va va être rude très
certainement pour ne pas en rester à un
taux minimal alors lequel il envers du
décor juste une phrase le l'envers du
décor c'est que si cette taxe si ce taux
est appliquée cela voudra dire que ce
sont les états dans lesquels les sièges
sociaux sont implantés qui percevront
cette nouvelle recette fiscale le
problème c'est qu'il n'ya aucun pays
pauvres aujourd'hui aucun pays du sud
qui possède de manière importante en
tout cas des sièges sociaux qui sont
installés sur leur sol donc il faudra
prévoir des mécanismes qui permettront
de redistribuer éventuellement cette
manne récoltée à l'échelle mondiale
philippe béchade eu cette précision
puisque le taux moyen de taxation des
entreprises aujourd'hui 22% et comme le
disait jean marie harribey les
négociations risquent d'être serrés
alors cette question est ce que les
multinationales euros auront leur mot à
dire
les milices tête du national je voudrais
préciser une chose le retour moyen
d'imposition est telle que calculée par
les installer ou accenture kpmg
en fait ce sont tous des cabinets qui
sont des spécialistes de l'e de désir
d'évasion fiscale de l'évitement fiscal
le taux moyen des multinationales et
deux sets et demi pour cent normalement
quand on parle des douze ennemis % que
les multinationales paye pas en irlande
en fait elles payent beaucoup moins que
ces douze ennemis elle paye 12 est mis
sur l'argent qui reste en irlande mais
s'il ne fait que transiter elle ne paye
rien et puis ensuite vous avez une façon
de robes de réduire encore la facture si
de négocier des rescrit fiscaux avec la
belgique la hollande notamment puisque
c'est le pays européen
si j'ose dire la meilleure à jiri en
termes de holding et le luxembourg
jacques le luxembourg certaine qu'il est
seul arrive presque à négocier des
forfaits fiscaux équivalent à 1 euro
symbolique
mais je pense qu'il ya vraiment une
affaire qui est entre a finalement de
faire bouger les lignes
c'est cette filiale de microsoft
microsoft landes island qui est
effectivement enregistrés dans un
cabinet à un cabinet d'avocats à dublin
plus précisément sur les dogues parce
que la zone franche se situe là mais
cette filiale irlandaise de microsoft en
fait son siège son enregistrement
fiscale et aux bermudes
et sur 260 milliards d'euros de
bénéfices ils ont payé tout simplement
0-0 et les bermudes
elles ont fait un chèque de 24 milliards
à microsoft l'esa qui a été ensuite
imposé mais quand vous voyez ce genre de
montant de 160 milliards qui n'a pas
supporté l'impôt donc si on met 15 % là
dessus on voit quand même qu'on la
récupère environ 40
l'enjeu vaut tant pour autant philippe
béchade est-ce que j'en reviens à ma
question est ce que ces multinationales
auront leur mot à dire finalement on
part en bd les multinationales à
l'accession à 15 % ça ce serait
quasiment de la taxation
oui mais elles vont protester pour la
forme parce que j'attends moi que les
bermudes que damas que quand même site
et en europe on a parlé beaucoup de
luxembourg belgique afin d'aider luxe on
peut également citer malte la crète et c
est ce que ces pays vont appliquer les
15%
donc ça sera appliquée dans des pays
d'europe qui se tiennent qui se tiennent
bien les coudes
mais le problème c'est que les villes
architecture actuelle de la mécanique
d'effacement de la fiscalité
si jamais l'irlande appliquer les 15%
ça serait juste remonté de 2 points be
mais il faudrait que tous les paradis
fiscaux à blick
or les multinationales évidemment vont
protester mais qu'est ce qu'elles vont
faire mais l'intérêt de la proposition
initiale de baden avait été de dire que
si un pays d'appliquer pas la
disposition adoptée communément alors
l'état chaque état pourrait faire payer
la différence entre le taux minimal
mondiale décidée et puis celui que les
paradis fiscaux qui resterait encore en
course appliquerait donc là je crois que
il
moyen de faire faire un pas véritable
dans la direction d'une meilleure
fiscalité et j'ajouterais parce que ça
c'est très important c'est que entre les
impôts payés par les grandes
multinationales et les impôts payés par
les petites et moyennes entreprises et à
fortiori par les ménages de particuliers
alors la différence est énorme
et donc si les dirigeants des
multinationales nous disent que 15 % et
21 % serait vraiment eu beaucoup trop
important mais que dirait que dix titres
alors pour tenir compte du fait que les
petites et moyennes entreprises pays des
taux qui sont déjà bien supérieures à ce
qu'elles payent en moyenne
monsieur b ça disait à juste titre que
en fait les 11 et demi pour ce les deux
nuits pour ça a été bien inférieure à
ahala dans la réalité
donc je pense que la faire payer la
différence entre le taux minimal
mondiale et puis celui qui est appliqué
par des états considérés comme des
paradis fiscaux serait un moyen
relativement efficace pour progresser
pour avancer vers l'avenir
ça permettrait peut-être aux états unis
et ses alliés repeint de reprendre la
main sur le plan fiscal mais pour
terminer est ce que ce projet-là des
chances finalement d'aboutir vous savez
que c'est une décision d'ordre politique
donc la politique avance en fonction des
rapports de force donc il n'y a aucune
loi naturelle qui impose que les la
fiscalité sur les bénéfices des
entreprises soit la plus minimale
possibles dont combien ont fait le choix
de pouvoir faire face au gigantesque
prises qui sont peut-être devant nous
hélas le dénuement des hôpitaux le
dénuement du matériel de soin et le
dénuement en matière de personnel
médical pendant l'année et demi que nous
voulons de passer à montrer qu'il y
avait des gigantesques besoins à
satisfaire et donc là il y à des choix
politique au sens noble du terme qui
s'imposent pour pouvoir résoudre ont
contribué à résoudre un certain nombre
de questions aujourd'hui vital et je
souligne de mots vital philippe béchade
pourra terminer
la mise en place de cette taxe que vous
avez qualifié de serpent de mer ça sera
une réalité votre avis je pense que les
choses vont se faire assez lentement
vous savez que le président de
l'eurogroupe c'est pascal de nos goûts
qui est le ministre des finances
irlandais mâle lui il est évidemment
voir debout contre une imposition à 15%
quand dans son pays on pratique douze
ennemis en ce qui concerne les paradis
fiscaux on peut effectivement leur
imposer une taxation mais il faut bien
faire attention entre les pays qui sont
déclarés comme paradis fiscaux et cela
risque de se faire punir et ceux qui ne
sont pas reconnus comme des paradis
fiscaux
le benelux mais également comme je lé
site est la crête iliaque il ya plein de
petits territoires qui ne rentrent pas
aujourd'hui dans la catégorie des
paradis fiscaux auxquels on peut
infliger des sanctions ou imposer une
déclaration et de effectivement
collaboré avec les autorités
merci philippe béchade rédacteur en chef
de la bourse au quotidien l'union
européenne qui a d'ailleurs établi une
liste noire des paradis fiscaux
merci à vous jean marie harribey membres
des économistes atterrés chiant